(air whooshing)
- Good morning, Believe Nation,
today we're going to talk about
strategies on how to
improve your productivity.
Rule number three is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for my take, and some
special bonus clips as well,
and as always, as you hear
people saying something
that's really relevant to
you, please leave it in the
comments below, put quotes around it too,
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(pleasant pop music)
- How much time does it
take to have a good idea?
Zero.
How much time does it take to be creative?
How much time does it take
to be loving and present
with your kids when you
tuck 'em in bed at night?
Zero, those do not require
time, they require space.
If you're wrapped up around a problem,
an issue, you know, backlog
of all kinds of things
unhandled and
inappropriately engaged with,
very difficult to have creative ideas,
be innovative, or be loving and present.
You need room.
Oh, come on, Leonardo
da Vinci had 24 hours.
Mother Teresa had 24 hours.
Johann Sebastian Bach had 24 hours.
You know, I know he didn't have WhatsApp,
but he had 20 kids, take your pick.
You need room.
(pleasant music)
- Here's how I want you to work through
your day from now on.
First, when you wake up, your goal
is not to go to the computer
and check your inbox.
We've got to tear you away from the inbox,
particularly if you
are a senior executive,
an owner of a business,
a person who has major
projects that you're moving forward.
If you are a customer
service person and your
job is to check email all day, then hey,
I get it, that's okay, but for most folks,
their real goal is not
to check email all day,
it's to be productive and get things done,
so unless it's your job
to be on the email drop,
where you respond to everything
within 10 or 15 minutes,
then this is really about
taking ownership of your
life again, and I think
those folks who are in that
position will also find
this to be very inspiring,
and a wise guide to
working more effectively.
So, let's get to it.
Here's what I want you to do.
When you wake up each
day, let's talk about
productivity in general.
When you wake up each day, the first thing
to do is not go to the computer.
The first thing to do is go exercise,
go for a walk, take a
long shower, it's to open
your body and engage, and
in doing that process,
whatever it is for you,
some people it's a long run,
some people it's a longer shower,
some people it's a walk
around the neighborhood,
when you're doing that,
here's what I want you
to ask yourself, a
couple simple questions.
First, I want you to ask
yourself what am I excited
about today, or could I create
to be excited about today?
So, what is it?
I want you to begin your
day with enthusiasm.
Optimism is the magical
formula that creates
greater happiness in our lives.
To have something to look forward to.
Steal away someone's
vision for a good future,
and you quickly see them
fall into depression,
but when we have a great
connection to something
in the future that we look forward to,
even if it's just this day, that creates
the charge within us, so walk around,
take your laps, do whatever you have to do
in the morning, but ask
yourself, what is it
that I'm excited about today, or could be
enthusiastic about today?
Second, ask what am I
grateful for in life today?
You know, what am I so
appreciative of having?
You know, I know a lot of
these videos I'm talking
so fast at you, but as
you get to know my work,
I'm a pretty soulful guy,
and I'm an incredibly
grateful person for all that
I've been able to create,
all, you know, all the stages I get on,
all the people who come to our seminars,
the brands I've built, the opportunities
I've been blessed to have.
Even the challenges I've
been blessed to have,
and I think that, coming
from that place spiritually
each day really opens you up to something
magnificent in the
universe, maybe you agree.
And so, ask what can I
be enthusiastic about,
what am I grateful for,
and then ask, third,
what am I committed to
making happen today,
no matter what?
If we start from those
positions, then we're in good,
then we're in a good space,
then I want you to drink
lots of water and have
a healthy breakfast.
Lots of water, healthy breakfast.
Now, we can start thinking about work.
Deal?
This is the secret to
you performing better.
We've got to get you in the
right mindset in the morning,
we've got to take care
of your physical needs,
of hydration and nourishment,
then walk into the office,
then get ready to work.
- Point number two, you
want to make sure you're
producing the right things.
You could make a ton of decisions,
check off a lot of email,
make a ton of phone calls,
and at the end of the
day, the end of the week,
the end of the quarter,
the end of the year,
not have accomplished
all that much at all.
The way that I get around
that is looking at my
list of goals, looking
at my list of priorities,
looking at my list of
to-dos, and asking myself
which of these, if done,
would make all of the
other ones easier or unnecessary?
This is a great way to narrow your focus
to the most important domino that,
when flipped over, will then
topple 20, 30, 40 others.
One thing I keep in mind a lot,
this is from Steve Jobs,
innovation is saying
no to a thousand things, and really,
if you want to do anything impressive,
anything incredible, you have to say no
to 99% of what comes at you.
And that certainly applies to email,
which is effectively everyone
else's agenda for your time.
We all have the same 24 hours in the day,
and if you're like, "I don't have time,
"I can't sleep, I need
to cut back on sleep,
"I need to do this, I need to do that,"
if you don't have time,
you don't have priorities.
That's it.
- Your environment is so important,
and if you look at B
performers or C producers,
they really don't pay a lot of attention
to their environment, and so they get very
distracted, there's lots of noises,
their phones are going off, maybe there's
news in the background, maybe there's
messy environments all around them,
maybe there's toxic people.
What I'm suggesting to you as the second
piece of technology to really 100 times
your productivity is this:
Install environments of
tight bubbles of total focus.
The way I run my work life on certain days
I am very hard to reach,
and I challenge you,
with great love and respect, be very hard
to reach during key times of your week.
I mean, I see a lot of people,
and it's not judging them,
it's just observing them,
every time their phone
rings, they check it,
or they have, you know,
these loud notifications,
so they're constantly being distracted,
and we know what the research says,
the research says we spend 2.1
hours a day in distraction.
We spe-, and it takes
21 minutes to refocus
your focus after you've been distracted.
So if you are being
distracted by notifications,
checking your phone,
checking your Twitter feed,
checking your Facebook
feed, looking on Instagram,
checking all the different platforms,
that is going to destroy your focus.
So the second piece of
technology is create these
tight bubbles of total
focus, and the way I do it
is I have certain days that
I label as creative days,
and on those creative days,
I actually go device free,
and on those days, I'm very hard to find,
and on those days, I'm in total solitude,
and on those days, I go to certain places,
I call them my Menlo
Labs, just like Edison had
his Menlo Lab, and these
places are very minimalist,
and there's no one there, and that's where
I do my best work, so install these tight
bubbles of total focus and create these
Menlo Labs where you're
sort of, you're completely
distraction free, and
then you will find your
brain will drop from the beta state
into the alpha state,
where you will do your
best work and get your best ideas.
- But I think one of the
biggest mistakes that
entrepreneurs make, especially
as they grow their business,
or in the beginning, when
they're crippled by this
thought of quality work
versus just doing it,
you know, like, smart
work versus just work,
is when you start judging it too much,
you start leaving yourself
out of opportunity for
serendipity, and upside
that you can't see.
There's been a lot of
things that, on paper,
may look like busy work,
going to, you know,
just kissing babies and shaking hands,
or just replying to everybody on Twitter,
things that not everybody
thinks is the best
scalable use of my time, that
has led to enormous upside,
because it wasn't obvious
when you first did it,
including a video sh-,
including, 10 years ago,
in a month, sitting
upstairs doing a video show,
where everybody's like, "We
needed you for that hour
"to sell wine, or to
reorganize our operations,
"why are you putting a video on YouTube,
"what is YouTu-," like, got it?
It ended up being the
biggest, single biggest
decision of my career up to this point,
transitioning myself into a media property
and a brand from just being
an operator on this floor.
Wasn't obvious, felt like
it could've been busy work,
and there's been other things
that I've done like that
that have been busy work,
you know, I'm trying to think
of a good example, but
like, a million things that
we've stopped and started
that didn't become real,
it happens with us every day in our team,
so I think that, I think
that you don't always know.
I think you find out after the fact,
and I think to have a
long 40 to 60 year old
professional career that's successful,
as long as you're learning
in year one, three, seven,
nine, 12, patterns, start becoming more
self-aware about yourself,
understanding your
strengths and weaknesses,
you start having less
just busy work and more high impact work,
and that's what's happened in my career.
- Stop multitasking.
Like, I used to do so
many different things,
I used to actually work in different jobs,
like, do this, do that,
see, the problem about
multitasking, some people can do it,
but the problem is, like,
whatever you're doing,
like, those different things,
they're going to suffer.
Like, you're going to do lots of
different things really badly.
So when I make videos, Infinite Waters,
I'm just doing this,
like I do consultations,
I just do that.
I don't do a whole lot, but
I have a lot of concentrated
focus on one thing for a
sustained period of time,
which is why we bloom and blossom, baby.
But you don't want to do that, do you?
You're like, "I want to
open up a gym, Ralph!
"A restaurant, too!
"Now I'm takin' my kids for a walk,
"then I'm going cycling,
then I'm going to the beach,
"then I'm doing this, then I'm doing that,
"then I'm doing, oh my goodness gracious."
You're giving yourself way too much to do,
you're making it harder than it has to be,
and that's why you lose the enthusiasm
for what you want to
do, so you don't end up
becoming productive at all.
So to become more productive,
just do one thing,
and do it well, or just have fun doing it,
whatever you want to do.
- So I have a lot of
thoughts on productivity,
I've talked a lot about
it on this channel,
whether we're talkin'
about bringin' on a team
or chunkin' your days and doin' different
things on different days,
or not checking email,
or not having a phone,
and some of the crazier
things that I do to stay
productive and do as much
work as I do in both my businesses now,
but today I actually want
to talk about mindset.
I think that mindset is super important,
is extremely critical if you are thinking
about how do I be
productive, 'cause you have
had really productive
days, you have had days
where you've watched a video or something
set you off, or you had a conversation,
or you read a book, or something happened,
and you were on fire
for the rest of the day,
and then you wake up
the next day and that's,
that feeling is gone, I mean,
you're not as productive,
and even if you follow all the strategies,
you're applying the tactics,
you say you're going to
do this this day, you
say you're not going to
check your phone, you say
you're going to bring on a team,
you say you're going to
apply this schedule and
chunk your time, all of these ideas,
you don't always go and do them.
Because you have the wrong mindset,
because you're not in the zone,
and so, for me, what I want
to do, and what I try to do
in my life, and I encourage
you to do in yours,
is set up that proper
mindset every single morning.
And I'm actually touching
on this in the next
book that I started
writing, is creating that
morning routine, creating
that morning ritual
that gets you alive, every day.
So instead of randomly comin' across it,
maybe you watch this video
and you get inspired,
that's great, but what do
you do every single day?
'Cause I don't want it to happen on 4:00
on a Friday afternoon, I want it to happen
at 7:30 every morning, every day,
so that I'm set for an
amazing productive day
every single day, you can design that,
instead of just reacting
to what comes into you.
And so one of the things
that I do is I have
a daily reminder, and I
wrote myself a quick note
on what I want to feel
every day, and where I may
hold myself back, and my own limitations,
reminding me to play a
bigger game, and I'll read
it to you, this is what I
read to myself three times
in the morning before I go off and start
everything else that I have to do.
Maybe you'll like it, maybe you won't.
This is mine: Today, I
will push myself to be my
absolute best, to believe more, care more,
and try harder, I vow
not to let distractions,
scheduled changes, or fear
prevent me from being great.
I will make every minute
count because my time
is running out, I have
the ability to change
the world and it's my
responsibility to do so.
Three times, I read that every morning,
and then I put on my music,
and then I, you know,
do a whole bunch of other
things that are part
of my morning routine,
but it gets me set up,
and that's what I want you to think about.
Think about what you do
every single morning,
'cause you don't wake
up pumped and energized,
right, that alarm clock went off,
you're waking up with the sun, or whatever
you're wakin' up, most
people don't wake up
super pumped and
energized, even if you have
a passion for what you're
doing, and you're looking
forward to the day ahead, you still have
to get out of bed and go do something,
and I want you to figure
out ways to change
your state, and to go
from that sluggish start
into productivity as soon as possible,
and so, thinking about
what are the emotions
that you want to be
feeling, whether it's calm,
whether it's excitement,
whether it's happiness,
whether it's ambition,
like, what is it that
you want to feel in the
morning that you want to
carry through to the rest of the day,
and then what do you need to do every day
to feel that in the morning?
Whether it's listening
to a podcast or reciting
some daily reminders,
listening to some music,
reading a book, watching a video,
schedule that in for yourself so you set
yourself up for an
amazingly productive day
every single day, by design, with intent,
with purpose, to create something amazing.
So that's my take, I
made this video because
BestyouPRO asked me to,
so if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover in the next edition
of Believe Life, leave it
down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd love to know what
you took from this video,
who had the most meaningful message,
what you're going to
immediately apply to your
life or to your business,
leave it down in the
comments below, I'm going
to join the discussion.
If you also want to add
your own productivity hacks
that we didn't cover in this video,
please share it, I'm
sure it'll be extremely
valuable for the entrepreneurs
watching this episode.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Jay Kahn,
Jay, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting that picture,
the tribute picture to
your Instagram account,
I really, really, really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself, and
whatever your one word is,
much love, have an amazing day,
I'll see you soon.
(air whooshing)
- How do you create room?
Well, one of the things
I uncovered over these
35 years in developing,
really, just unfolding
this methodology, is
that you get control with
five stages, or five steps, and there are
six horizons that we have commitments,
that the more clarity
you have at all those
six horizons, the more
you're going to trust
your judgments about what
you do, and your priorities,
I couldn't get it any simpler than this.
(clears throat)
Those five steps, pretty simple, actually.
I didn't make these up, I recognized them.
All right, this is how
you get your kitchen
under control, you get
your company under control,
and you get your
consciousness under control.
Doesn't happen by itself.
Any of you ever had your
kitchen out of control?
Anybody ever come home and it looked like
your kitchen had been attacked?
Oh my God, and you got friends
coming over in an hour,
and you're supposed to cook spaghetti.
Oh no, what's the first thing you did
besides drink or call out for dinner?
First thing you did was you
looked at what was not right.
You identified something
that's not on cruise control
in that environment or echo system.
That's, you noticed what
had your attention, right?
Then what did you do?
You decided, "What does that stuff mean?
"Ooh, that's a dirty
dish, oh, that's a spice,
"oh, that's a clean dish,
oh, that's good food,
"oh, that's bad food."
You clarified exactly
what those things are that
are not on cruise control.
Then what did you do?
You organized them where they go.
You put dirty dishes in the dishwasher,
you put good food in
the fridge, et cetera.
Once you determined what it means,
you parked it where it should
go, then what did you do?
You looked at the whole
scene, you stepped back,
reflected on the whole gestalt.
Looked at the time,
pulled out maybe a recipe,
and then you pulled out
butter and started to melt it.
Now, that's how you get
your kitchen under control,
but that's also how you get your
consciousness under control.
If I were to sit down
with you and you said,
"God, things are feeling,
oh, overwhelming!"
First thing I'm going to
do, capture everything
that has your attention.
That takes one to six hours, by the way,
for most people, just to
identify what's got your mind.
(clears throat)
Then we're going to go
through each one of them
and decide what's the
very next action step
required for that thing,
and what's the final
outcome that you're
committed to finish about it?
The clarification step.
Then we're going to work
with you to customize,
how do I keep track of
the calls I need to make,
the errands I need to run,
the stuff I need to talk
to my life partner about,
where do I put those things
so that my head is not trying to do it?
By the way, your head is a crappy office.
Anything you're trying to
manage just in your head,
believe me, you will
over or underreact to it
if it's just there.
And that's one of the things
that's happened in the last
15 years since I wrote the first edition
of Getting Things Done,
is how much the cognitive
scientists have now
validated the fact that
your head is for having ideas,
but not for holding 'em.
As a matter of fact, if you're
trying to hang on to more
than four meaningful things
in your head, you're toast.
So building the external brain
requires that you capture
the stuff that has your attention,
clarify actions and outcomes,
organize the results
of that in some external
trusted system so that you can
then step back and reflect on all of that,
and then decide to have a
beer instead of any of it.
But that's a high performance beer.
I'm not voting for
alcohol as a way of life,
I'm just self-disclosing,
I love good beer.
Poland's a great place
for that, I've discovered.
So that's, those five steps, by the way,
are how we basically work with people,
what we train people
about, and most people,
even though these are simple,
have a huge improvement
opportunity in terms
of making sure that you
externalize your commitments
at multiple levels,
so that you can see 'em from
where you need to see 'em.
- So what do you think holds people back?
They, they, they know
what they want to do,
but they just can't keep
the habit, they do it once,
and then they fall off the
train, and then next month
they do it again, and
they fall off the train,
how do you make that consistent?
- Well, you just keep, you
just keep working at it
and working at it, the
best way of all is to plan
it in advance; instead of sitting down,
never start work without
a list, and never start
work without prioritizing your list.
People sit down and they
say, "Well, before I make
"a list, I'll check a little
email, check a little spam,
"send something to my
friend, see what's going
"on YouTube," and so on and so forth,
and then they look up and it's 10:00,
and they haven't done anything of value.
So what you do is you have to s-,
is say, you know, "Well," you know,
what do they say, if you start it right,
it'll work out right, so start it as,
on your most important task, and do that
until it becomes a habit,
and here's an interesting
thing about checking email is when you
check email, it triggers
the release of dopamine
in your brain, dopamine is a drug,
and by the way, there's all kinds of books
and articles and
scientific studies on this,
and dopamine is the same drug in cocaine,
and what it does is it's
triggered every time
you have a shiny object or something new
or different or interesting or sparkly.
If a telephone rings next
to you, you go "Bing!"
your brain releases
endorphins, and you can't
hardly wait to see what it is.
So you're talking to
somebody, and you could be
talking to somebody about
something very serious,
and your telephone goes off, "Bing!"
Your whole mind goes blank.
The middle of a conversation stops,
so you grab for you phone, you pick it up,
you look at it, you check
it out and everything else,
and then you come back, if
you're working on a task,
it takes an average of 17
minutes to get back to the task,
and then there's another
distraction, so another 17 minutes.
Average adult is checking
their email between,
and their phone, between
95 and 145 times a day.
- That's crazy.
- Which means they are like
Attention Deficit Disorder dogs,
they're just literally running
around, back and forth,
the whole day, at the end of
the day, they're exhausted.
By the way, USA Today
and Harvard have proved
that you lose one IQ
point for every hour that
you leave your email on,
at the end of the day,
you've lost 10 IQ points,
you actually become
stupider throughout the day, dumber,
and here's a, I ask this of my audiences,
I say, "Have you ever finished a day where
"you don't think you've
accomplished anything,
"you get on email,
responding to bings and beeps
"and rings and so on all day,
and at the end of the day,
"you go home and honey says,
'What do you want for dinner,'
"and you say, 'I don't know,
I don't care, anything.
"'I just want a drink.'"
Because you're so exhausted,
you cannot even decide
(audio cuts out) sit there and basically
like you've just been, you know,
punched in the side of the head,
because your brain, your brain is dead,
and you lose 10 IQ
points, you get stupider
throughout the day,
you've got to turn that
darn thing off if you
want to remain sharp.
(audio cuts out) develop a habit, you say,
"I'm going to develop a
habit, and I'm going to give
"myself my reward, and my
reward will be to check
"my email after I've
finished my first task."
So, all of success in
life is task completion.
Let me repeat that, I just
had a long conversation
with an entrepreneur, he
almost fell of his chair.
I was coaching him, and he said he'd
never heard that before,
and then I spoke to,
with this group I was
telling you in Japan,
I told them the same thing,
and they were just flabbergasted.
Is, the key to success in
life is task completion.
If you don't complete
tasks, you have no future,
and so, if task completion is the key,
then what you do is you
complete more and more
important tasks, and
if you start every day
by completing the most important task,
your brain actually releases endorphins.
Now, endorphins is another chemical,
and it's only released
when you do something
that is life enhancing,
and what that means
is when you do something
that is good for you,
that enhances your
life, that furthers you,
it makes you happy, it releases energy,
it raises your self-esteem, I sort of say,
"If you want to be a
winner, how do be a winner,
"well, you win, and winning
means you cross a finish line."
So if you start and complete a task,
you're actually winning,
and you get a feeling
of being a winner, which
gives you a suffusion
of energy, and inspiration, and it drives
you and motivates you to want to get that
feeling again, so how do
you get that feeling again?
You start to complete another task.
So I've developed a
habit, and people who are
successful developed a habit of starting
and completing tasks, so my wife comes in
and says, "Dinner's in five minutes,"
so I look at my list and I say,
"Okay, there's a five minute task,"
and I get ready to start and
complete a five minute task.
And each time you complete a task,
you get a burst of endorphin,
the bigger the task,
the more endorphin, the more endorphin,
the more quickly you
become addicted to starting
and completing important
tasks, and every single
successful person has a
reputation for starting
and completing important tasks.
You want the job done,
give it to him or her.
You want the product served on time,
you want the product
completed, you want the
product manufactured, shipped, delivered,
give it to him, give it to
her, give it to that company.
'Cause they always deliver.
That's the best reputation you can
have if you want to get rich.